et pour en parler nous sommes avec
fatima benomar militante associations
féministes les effrontés bonsoir c'est
ma baignoire merci d'être avec nous
alors on l'a vu un plusieurs féministes
qui sont venus manifester en marge de la
passation de pouvoir entre christophe
castaner et gérald darmanin c'était
important selon vous de mettre la
pression dès le premier jour oui
effectivement ça a été une première
réaction un peu pulsionnel il ya eu deux
rassemblements rien qu'aujourd'hui
et c'est vrai qu on n'attendait pas
grand chose des politiques publiques
contre les violences faites aux femmes
on a assez dit que tout ce qui s'était
passé au moment du grenelle c'était très
peu de moyens pour beaucoup de
communication mais au moins au moment du
grenelle contre les violences faites aux
femmes le gouvernement avait admis
qu'ils avaient deux grands secteurs où
il y avait un réel problème c'était la
police et la justice qui était dans le
parcours des femmes victimes de viols et
de violences conjugales et de violences
sexuelles et c'est parce que les
policiers ne prenez pas les plaintes
parce que nous allions des qualifiés le
viol ont lutté qualifiant en agression
sexuelle parce que ce sont des
classements sans suite à gogo faut
savoir qu'en france au plus haut niveau
de l'état on admet quelqu un pour cent
des violeurs qui sont condamnés et le
premier remaniement après le grenelle en
cdd qui lui avoir des gestes forts
c'est-à-dire au moins à la tête de la
police et de la justice des personnes
qui sont sensibilisés sur ces questions
là et là on a exactement l'inversé
on a comme premier flic de france un
homme qui est accusé par deux femmes de
viol et pas n'importe quelle forme de
viol c'est-à-dire des femmes qui disent
qu'il a abusé de postes de pouvoir
en tant que maire et entente et
personnes en responsabilité à l'ump pour
monnayer entre guillemets contre des
rapports sexuels des services qu'elle
lui demandait et on a de l'autre côté à
la tête par en tant que garde des sceaux
un homme ouvertement anti féministe je
vous passe les tirs à a2
enfin venir leur donner moi ça l'image
de nos marques on va revenir sur le cas
de monsieur dupont moretti
dans quelques instants un nom dans leur
si vous le voulez bien
concernant gérald darmanin vous dites
voilà accusations de viol effectivement
il ya une enquête mais gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement ou rappelle
effectivement le pouvoir de bénéficier
de la présomption d'innocence qui
prévaut dans notre droit français ça ne
veut rien dire pour vous la présomption
d'innocence dans le doute on s'abstient
et on n'est pas ministre c'est ça en
tout cas quand on nomme des ministres
on ne discrimine pas si on n'aime pas
certaines personnes c'est la discrétion
du pouvoir c'est à dire que un chef de
l'état qui choisit des ministres selon
les messages qu'il n'en voyait la
population selon les politiques qu'il
veut mener s'il ya une personne déjà ça
fait plusieurs semaines en été même les
avocats de la plaignante de monsieur
darmanin disent que c'est assez
scandaleux je suis d'accord avec elle
que le gouvernement exprime bruyamment
son soutien à barbe à anzin que ce soit
madame six dates ndiaye qui était porte
parole du gouvernement
où que ce soit nicole belloubet qui
avait même rajouté cette phrase
incroyable
au demeurant c'est un très bon ministre
ça n'a rien à voir avec la choucroute
excusez-moi l'expression mais là c'est à
dire que le président assume d'émettre
un poste absolument stratégique et un
poste de pouvoir suprême un homme qui
est visé par des femmes c'est à dire que
rien que le fait de lui donner à ce
point sa confiance il est déjà en train
d'accuser les accusatrices de mentir et
c'est pas comme ça on va peut-être pas
les sur le fond du dossier mais c'est
pas beau c'est qu'il est vide c'est un
dossier où il ya des échanges sms ou
darmanin dit à sa victime
comment je peux faire pour me faire
pardonner c'est bien qu'il ya quelque
chose à se faire pardonner
alors je vais bien la présomption
d'innocence à ce moment là moi je dis
pas ils attendent la fin des
investigations mais au moins
et pendant ce temps là pendant qu'il ya
présomption d'innocence mais aussi
possibilité que ces femmes qui ne sont
pas concertés dise la vérité tout
simplement qu'il se s'abstiennent de
risquer de mettre un premier flic de
un homme qui abuse de sa situation de
pouvoir pour imposer des rapports
sexuels en tout cas là pour doter
spectateurs sachez que la cour d'appel
de paris a demandé la reprise des
investigations le 11 juin et quant à
gérald darmanin lui il confirme avoir eu
une relation sexuelle avec la plaignante
mais selon lui librement consentis vous
aviez commencé à parler du nouveau
ministre de la justice monsieur dupont
moretti
là encore vous n'êtes pas enchanté par
cette nomination
absolument pas monsieur moretti ne s'est
jamais caché de ses opinions
profondément anti féministe avec
vraiment un discours qui incarne tout ce
qu'on dénonce par rapport à ce qu'on
appelle la culture du viol c'est-à-dire
que quand il dit une faute d'une femme
à 30 ans on n'est plus une potiche
incapable de dire non et ben désolé
monsieur moretti j'accompagne des
milliers de victimes
on a assez produits de travaux sur les
systèmes de sidération
et oui il ya des femmes puis dans des
situations d'emprise ou des situations
de supérieurs hiérarchiques public qui
leur imposent des comportements
absolument déplacé sur leur lieu de
travail
effectivement on peut avoir beaucoup de
mal à se défendre
je passe sur les commentaires sur l'
affaire dsk ce sont des copains qui
s'offrit du bon temps je rappelle quand
même que c'était une affaire assez
lourde de proxénétisme ou en ramener des
personnes en situation de prostitution
où dsk avait dit lui même devant les
juges c'est vrai que j'ai été très
brutal où ils s'envoyaient des sms en
parlant de ces jeunes ferment ciation
prostitution en disant est ce que tu
ramènes du matériel etc etc
quand l affaire de georges tron il ya
une femme qui dit la plaignante qui dit
lors de l'entretien d'embauché
j'ai dit que je savais faire de la
réflexologie et que son commentaire
s'est désolé mais quand une femme dit ça
c'est qu'il est là pour pécho je cite
ses 7 aces ces termes exacts c'est à
dire que en gros une vielle l'a bien
cherché une femme n'a pas apparu de
réflexologie ou deux
massage à ce moment là elle n'a pas se
plaindre plus tard de viol ou
d'agression sexuelle qu'elle peut subir
c'est quand même extrêmement grave et
encore tout à l'heure il était en train
de nous dire pendant la passation de
pouvoir la justice ne seront pas dans la
rue ni sur les réseaux sociaux ni dans
les médias
certes elle se rend ou en france elle ne
se rend pas dans les tribunaux puisqu'on
estime au plus haut de l'état comme je
disais tout à l'heure qui a qu'un pour
cent des violeurs qui sont condamnés il
ya un vrai problème et sans les réseaux
sociaux et sambi tout oser me dire que
monsieur barry stein serait aujourd'hui
condamné osé me dire que monsieur
matzneff qui peut encore il ya pas
longtemps le copain de toute
l'intelligentsia aurait été enfin
conspué comme il le mérite
jamais sans la pression des féministes
de la rue et tous qui s'exprimait un
moment dans les réseaux sociaux avec me
to avec des millions de femmes qui
exprimait en direct les viols qu'elles
ont vécu le harcèlement sexuel jamais le
gouvernement le soir et ne s'en seraient
emparés donc un moment monsieur mort et
il devrait admettre avec humilité et il
fait l' inverse face à l'isoc et de
beaucoup qu'il ya un réel problème au
niveau de la justice quant à la
condamnation des viols et des violences
et merci fatima benomar d'avoir été avec
mon militante associations féministes
les effrontés